so alhamdulillah we are starting shallow
fala the work here and fellow down in
the place inshallah is gonna be
inshallah the hub to do clean up the
floors everywhere so what we're gonna do
is we're going to show you the before
after and after the videos what we're
going to do the first thing is seen the
carpet do this up and then we're going
to set up this to do the same okay guys
why are we in out here today we are here
because we're moving into a new studio
and what this and we need chairs to sit
on on tables to video on so what do you
wanna do now is we're gonna go there
inshallah and look around a fiber stop
[Music]
this would be perfect but obviously with
the limited finances we have you need to
spend efficiently so what we're gonna do
is we're gonna look for something like
this or maybe in a second answer
the problem sister so what we're doing
now is would clean up the studio
it's got an extra clean now is the time
that you put together to do
[Music]
let me ask you guys a question have you
ever felt overwhelmed been in despair
the fact that you living in the West and
you want to practice your Islamic values
and it's so hard
you're being thrown feminism capitalism
liberalism all these isms not only that
on top of that you have got Muslims
coming and telling you this is how loud
this is Haram it's disciplining or this
is a right opinion and this sect and
this group and you want to pull your
hair out
well we have a solution for you guys at
Salaam our organization we want every
single Muslim to know their religion and
hold their head up high not only that
misconceptions and lies and deceptions
that's been found to Islam do you not
want answers we all do and that's
exactly what we're gonna do so follow me
guys as I give you a tour of our Salaam
organization and show you guys in sha
Allah our Salaam studios where we will
be recording our videos and our content
in sha Allah also another branch of our
organization is Salaam + e learning
platform where you will be learning your
religion from A to Z
follow me and let's find out so I cannot
allow you but I can't so and welcome to
some studios brothers and sisters you
saw the transformation from before and
after well guess what we're gonna show
you more of that what we're gonna do is
gonna give you guys a little tour of the
Salaam studios our local just in a
nutshell is sharing affection love and
mercy
sadly in today's time who was taught
this new Hellfire doom that's what we're
told 100 that is a part of religion that
exists however the mercy the affection
love and sharing that is a key factor in
Salah so we're going to go and give you
guys a little tour each set and what
we're about
does the job Ali I'm here bro are you
Nathan become a celebrity yeah yeah I'm
here bro salam studio makeover oh good
yeah cease to be game taller and taller
are you enjoying yourself I'm not really
no okay yeah yeah lavalla sister this
state is called the house inshallah
we're going to be doing here is we're
going to do reaction videos we're gonna
have guests coming all over the world in
Charlotte Singhania have a nice children
environment Ryan listen to a thing you
said he just speaks so fast just
translating to English please Turkish
studios are mine yes you're inside you
I'm gonna enjoy stuff yeah yeah what's
you to stay on that calcium
so we just came from the chill-out set
to this this is going to be based upon
knowledge inshallah so and all the time
yes Angela is good to have hella fun
relax sometimes life is not always about
Haram even though we do implement that
in our life sometimes we should take
matters a bit seriously and this is
where chef Mohammed thoroughness
inshallah we'll retain a major part in
that is won't only our self development
but also when it comes to topics of
Matilde needs knowledge we always refer
to people of knowledge inshallah and
also sure Mohammed off man who you guys
might have remembered from understand by
these are the car academics academic
topics which we want to be able to cover
in this project by going a little bit
more in-depth seeing what these things
Allah be able to do so yeah sometimes we
see people always respect them are they
fine you know if I do something wrong
the first a part it's not about and this
is what we're going to be showing in
this section
inshallah let's move on to a next
okay guys so on this set some of you
guys especially youngsters they'd like
to see a lot of animations and flag
things flying all over the place
on here on this step we're going to be
doing it doing animations so sometimes
you see us flying in rocket or sometimes
you see us in Dubai or France or Belgium
oh yeah with you thank you for
correcting me okay so this one of the
steps we will be using a lot of motion
graphics and animation to bring you
quality videos let's go this is we're
gonna be doing the heavy weight work
this is where we're gonna be talking
about really important ideas really
important philosophy is really important
ideologies this moment we're talking
about liberalism and Marxism and
communism and feminism and this is what
we're going to talk about what the
scholars of the post enlightenment the
pre-enlightenment the Renaissance all of
those different time periods have said
this we're going to assess their
consistencies in their inconsistencies
this we're going to talk about some of
the contradictions associated with those
ideas so this is an informed place to be
all of this and much more will be
happening in this very booth looks more
like a barmy what's this
hey guys so this said what's this about
it was me the cool wise in the cool
because I kind of designed it besides
the point let's come to the main crux of
the matter on this specific show every
single week Michelle I'm going to try my
best to tackle major misconceptions that
are thrown towards Islam so all these
miss concept misconceptions that front
was Islam and lots of non-muslims are
curious and almost want to know this is
our religion we want to know exactly
what our sources say not what Tom Dick
and Harry says so in this specific show
that's what I'll be doing every single
week on this board as you can see a
classified photo will be put here and
I'll be discussing that specific
misconception obviously this is not for
myself I'm not that knowledgeable our
teaches which you saw Sheikh Mohammed
Sheikh Mohammed both of them would
assist me myself specifically in doing
in-depth research be event event
occasion and also other matters as well
and they will give me that knowledge and
I will present him this to you guys in a
digestible way so you don't get stomach
ache in inshallah and that's how I'll be
doing shall on this platform not only
that so you guys can understand it in
detail I know you guys are like a bit of
imagery yes you will see things
happening inshallah so that's the main
aspect of it which will help you
understand in CrossFit so we're going
into the meeting room which is a really
important room we're gonna be doing our
meetings in it we're going to be doing
our brainstorming in it of course we
could do some of our lessons in it as
well which we're going to publish for
all of you guys to see let's take a look
inside
what we're talking about is the European
tour because part of our remit is going
to be exploring the world and obviously
spreading the message of Islam educating
people all across the world in places
like Europe South America Africa has
been Juicin effects international even
guys welcome to the editing room this is
where all the footage that we record on
the sets that we showed you all the
footage that we do outside or
documentaries and show movies that we
film are brought into this room and our
editing team bring it to life in an
amazing way with the latest technology
as you can see that we have rendering is
super fast so no more complaining and
waiting prefer an e lens the video
coming out with them with it and this is
where it all will be happening and for
the motion graphic videos with that
little extra edge you'll be sent to
Brighton to our graphic motions team
where they would add a little bit of
specialness in it so that's what's going
to be happening so insha'Allah we can
turn the world into a colourful place
[Music]
you
you